good morning John it's been a long
couple of days and I don't think anyone
can deny that and the problem is that
it's not gone it stopped being long days
for quite a while so this video is gonna
have to go ahead and come to you in four
parts and I'm gonna tell you what those
parts are now so that I don't forget
because I always forget what the parts
are part what does balloons part two is
me being weird to keep you entertained
because there's all these parts part
three is talking about the project for
awesome and part four is talking about
punishments so part one balloon first I
want to say that we falsely accused in
my tea of planting a fake balloon that
was in fact not MIT it was another of
the many competing teams
sorry MIT but that doesn't mean that you
didn't do certain dirty things it's not
gonna talk about that because we did
dirty things too the fact of the matter
is I think that DARPA wanted to learn a
lot of things from this project they
wanted to see how easy it could be to
rapidly mobilize a group of people to do
a specific task and whether that task is
to find red balloons or find a missing
child or blow-up strategic targets all
of that is very interesting to the
military but John it became very clear
to me as I was doing the red balloon
thing that this was very similar to
being a resistance fighter we were
taking in intelligence from an
intelligence network and then
dispatching real people in our network
to go confirm that intelligence and it
seems to be very clear that if I was a
member of the rebellion in the Star Wars
universe the Empire would be not a big
fan of that ability it also seems clear
to me that I would like my government to
know how to anticipate and deal with
groups of people who want to do this in
order to hurt people and I also want
them to have a good idea of how to
disrupt that so it's not just finding
the balloons that's interesting it's
also learning how to disrupt the
intelligence network that's interesting
and that's what the nerdfighters were
doing and that's what MIT was doing and
that's what a lot of the other groups
are doing so there's a lot of really
interesting things going on and let's be
honest all's fair in love war and
balloon challenges I think that MIT did
a fantastic job and I know that there
MIT students and alumni among
nerdfighteria and we love all of you
nerds can't be turning on other nerds
here it was a game and it was well
played and as I said on Twitter we may
have only found nine out of the ten
balloons in the real world but
nerdfighteria you found all of the
balloons in my heart thing number two me
being weird this is the lamest thing in
the world to be excited about
it's my pill container it helps me
remember when to take my pill for
oh this time of you always view the
scene now I wish I had more time to play
video games thing number three the
project for awesome
December 17th is getting closer and
closer my friends in fact I think that
it's December 8th right now which means
that it's less than 10 days away that's
me doing math right there if you don't
know the project for awesome is very
basically it's a day in which all of
YouTube gets together and promotes
charities with their videos and then on
that day December 17th everyone tries to
use the same thumbnail in their video
and then a giant team of thousands and
thousands of people get together and
promote all of those videos at all the
ways that they can and basically they
fool YouTube's algorithms by commenting
and watching and favoriting and rating
all of those videos and it's a very fun
way to spend a Thursday of course this
is just a quick introduction to the
project for awesome is awesome this year
if you would like to know more please go
to nerdfighters calm right now pause the
video go right now and put in your email
address to the project for awesome
mailing list the little forum fingers on
the top left hand side of the page it's
impossible to miss all you have to do is
put your name and email address in there
and I promise promise promise as always
to never send you anything to do with
anything except for the project for
awesome so pause the video right now and
go do that and then unpause me thing
number 4 punishments so by now you all
know that I'm going to have spent 15
hours inside of a target to John's
punishment on the other hand it's still
up in the air and I'm kind of at a loss
one thing that I was thinking he could
do is maybe watch every single thing
that's on vlogbrothers in order without
sleeping which I think would take like
26 hours but if you the denizens of
nerdfighteria have any other suggestions
please leave them in the comments below
obviously I am now out of time so John
you will see me tomorrow with some very
exciting news